all right we are awaiting more results
in several crucial states that will
determine the outcome of this election
here with more fox news contributors ari
fleischer
and dan bongino uh with us all right ari
i heard you're going to outdo carl one
of the things we talked about now our
pollsters
matt towery john mclaughlin robert
kaheli
trafalgar group they got it right they
all saw the same thing
african-americans hispanics moving in
greater numbers in the lead up to this
election
you study this yeah sean if you remember
after 2012 when mitt romney lost to
barack obama i was part of a group that
said to grow the party republicans need
to do better with hispanics and
do better with blacks that is exactly
what donald
trump just did win loser draw
donald trump should be known for this
take a look at the numbers sean
black votes this is john mccain's vote
four percentage
of the black vote went to john mccain
six percent to mitt romney
eight percent to donald trump when he
ran for the first time
12 last night he has tripled john
mccain's number and doubled mitt
romney's
let's go to hispanics the hispanic vote
31
for mccain 27 for romney 28
for donald trump the first time he ran
32
last night hispanic vote for donald
trump
this is how you make inroads and i could
add the jewish vote too the jewish vote
went 30 percent
30.5 for donald trump
way up from his numbers that's the
highest they've gone since the 80s
so yes donald trump has expanded the
party in numerous ways and for all these
people to say racist racist
they're wrong wrong yeah it's it's so
fascinating
now if you take covert out of this
record low unemployment
for every demographic if you took that
part
out of the equation i i think it could
be so much higher and would have been so
much higher
but there's something that's emerging a
dan that i think ari's on to and that is
that i see the democratic party now as
the rich coastal elite party
you know right and then you got donald
trump standing up for working men and
women
donald trump standing up even by
building a border
less competition for jobs more jobs
higher wages for americans first
right so i see this donald trump's
version of the republican party uh as
the future
of a new republican party that stands up
for working men and women of all
backgrounds and races
you know sean i said on the network this
past saturday night before the election
that regardless of what happens
the republican party owes donald donald
trump a debt of gratitude for this
sean can we be candid i mean the series
of candidates we had running against
donald trump in 2016 were nice guys some
of them are friends
but do you honestly think any of them
would have beat hillary clinton
um a lot of them wouldn't have had any
appeal in wisconsin i mean the fact that
we're even talking about wisconsin and
michigan tonight
the fact that we're even talking about
them that they were close are close
uh you know we don't know i'm not sure
what the outcome will be at until every
vote is counted
but we're we're having these
conversations sean do you know what the
nickname for pennsylvania was for
republicans before donald trump
arie knows it was called fool's gold
because every republican would chase
pennsylvania
and get and face plant like a buffoon
and lose by 10 points
donald trump's up in pennsylvania right
now for the second election in a row
you owe the man a debt of gratitude for
telling working-class americans and
hispanics
yes you give a damn we care about you
we are not the party of the aristocrats
that's the democrats with their bow ties
and their foie gras lunches that's not
us we're the ones in this for you
and your work and your kids and your
healthcare think of all the states that
used to be competitive
ari virginia used to be competitive not
anymore colorado used to be competitive
donald trump made pennsylvania
competitive again
you know all these states the map got
smaller and smaller for republicans
you're saying it can grow
well let's look at the map tonight sean
i'm i'm not convinced arizona is over
for donald trump
no me either as part of a campaign where
a state was called one way then another
way then it was called no way and then
finally it was called the right way
so it wouldn't surprise me if arizona
changes keep your eyes on arizona it is
not over there yet we've got to see how
this count goes
and if trump gets pennsylvania and
arizona it's over and he's reelected
now will it happen we just have to wait
and see but do not rule it out i
absolutely think the number that he
needed in maricopa
tonight he hit in the first wave of
maricopa votes